*Musique épique* Après avoir été boxeur,
puis militaire,
Squeezie se met  aujourd'hui à une activité plus virile que ces deux dernières réunies
C'est la que je suis censé dire une punchline
*Musique épique*
Messieurs dames ! Une table  de ping-pong était trop chère pour nous
Du coup on acheté un HTC-Vive ce qui est... plus cher
Aujourd'hui on est sur un jeu de Ping-Pong en VR
C'EST PARTI BITCHIES !!
Nique sa mère
Ok alors écoutez on est sur Eleven Ping Pong dont je me souviens plus du nom
Un jeu auquel on peut jouer en multiplayer contre d'autres joueurs dans le monde
Le problème c'est que on a essayé tout à l'heure et il n'y avait personne qui voulait jouer au ping pong en ligne
Heureusement, l'option jouer seul comme un puceau est présente
Clément est ce que on est un amateur ?
Un semi pro ?
un professionnel ou est ce que on est un joueur de legende ?
Clément : LÉGENDE !!
Squeezie : Tu t'enflammes un peu gamin la !
PROFESSIONEL,
ce sera un excellent début, allez on y va
Attention ! SERVICE
*Rire*
Attend c'est le début, c'est normal 1-0 pour lui Clément!
ON Y RETOURNE
OUIIIIIIIIIIIIII TIEEEENS  *rire*
OH ! il sert il prévient même pas !!!
*Voix très aiguë * Oh l'mauvais joueur !!!
*voix normale* Toi je vais dislike toutes tes vidéos.
Attend j’arrête pas d'rater ma balle,  en fait c'est le casque est pas très stable
T'façon t'sais quoi j'vais t'dire un truc :
la musique elle était grave nulle
Clément : C'est vrai ?
Squeerie : Ca dégage
Oké 3-1 pour lui  la on se ressaisit tu connais la chinoise?
Putain....
MAIS EN MÊME TEMPS JE SUIS UN BABTOU J'FAIS UN TRUC D'ASIATS, qu'est que tu veut que ?
Putain mec j'me fais démolir la gueule c'est terrible
Pourtant j'suis un professionnel chuis un joueur de légende je jouais contre les plus grands
je jouais contre david Lafarge mon pote ! ET OUAIS ! C'est faux!
7-1 bon bah ça va on est bien comme on dit rien n'est jamais perdu
MAIS MERDE !
C'est bon c'est fini.
Bon ce que on va faire c'est que on va faire c'est un re-match ;
échauffement terminé.
C'est parti vas-y sert j'men bats les couilles. HOP LA !
Nan là par contre c'est trop mal fait.
Mec j'vais faire des gros smashs t'es prêt a voir des gros smashs?
PUTAIN ! J'ai pas touché la balle
Oh putain ! 8-0 c'est pas grave c'est pas grave rien n'est perdu
REGARDE
*rire*
T'A VU OU PAS ?? J'ai niqué un pigeon.
Oké joueur professionnel tu vas voir !
HOP LA !
Putain c'est hyper humiliant c'qui s'passe j'ai acheté la tenue et tout et je me... ALLEZ 1-1
c'est le début de la victoire pou Lucas Hauchard, bon j'avoue j'ai changé de difficulté j'ai mis en amateur
OH LE MEC IL FEINTE C'EST UN VIEUX GARS !
J'ai mis en amateur mais ça me permet voyez de comprendre un petit peu
comment ça marche un petit peu le ping-pong en RV.
Ça n'a rien à voir avec le ping-pong en.. En réalité euh..
Tout court finalement.
J'pense qu'il faut rester stable regarde :
j'vais rester stable regarde, regarde, regarde !
Tu vois ces jambes de grenouilles C'EST DES PILIERS ZOOM DESSUS
Franchement je suis over ridicule mais mec depuis que je fais ça je gagne
Autant te dire que je vais pas la lâcher cette position
Alleeeez ça marche trop bien *rire* c'est ridicule
En plus j'attrape un peu froid aux boules parce que l'air passe et on s'en fout
8/6 pour lui putain il remonte Clément je peux pas perdre contre l'amateur..
J'peux pas perdre contre l'amateur.
Ok..
Bloqués..
T'as vu ?
T'as vu la technique du.. je change une lettre ?
C'est fou hein ?
OHHH !
OH IL EST CHAUUD CLÉMENT ! Fils de...
Allez c'est en 11 points faut qu'je gagne celui-là.
OH
9-9 Clément c'est incroyable, c'est incroyable je vais battre un amateur.
Il fait quoi ?
Nan mais Clément c'est un vieux gars.. Mais vraiment..
Eh attend j'ai peur.. J'ai peur qu'il m'envoie un truc dans les boules
Mais il est pas marrant.. Mais c'est homme n'est pas drôle !
C'est pour ça que cet homme joue au ping-pong, c'est que dans la vie il ne peux rien faire d'autre
Ah il rage !
Casse pas la raquette bâtard
C'est le club qui te les prête.
AH NAN J'AI VOULU SMASHER !
Balle de match.
Clément tu crois en moi ?
*Souffle*
OUUUUUIIIIIIII !!!
OUUI !
Quoi ?
C'était pas en onze points ?
Mais c'est un sketch mec ?
Ah faut 2 points d'écart !
Mais Clément pourquoi tu m'le dis pas ?!
2 points d'écart !
Putain c'est pas grave c'est pas grave.
Tu vois les piliers ? Ils sont en place.
J'suis concentré, j'suis concentré, j'suis en train de try hard un mec dans un jeu de ping-pong virtuel.
Ma vie c'est ça !
'ttention..
OH OUI ! C'est passé ! Allez !Oh il rage de ouf mec !
C'est parti là, faut que je gagne celle-là.
*Win*
C'est la win.
Merci. Allez on est chaud !
On part sur un match en semi-pro.
La grenouille !
Oh il est chaud mec.
Ah par contre le point il dure beaucoup trop longtemps Clément !
Ah non ! En fait, le problème c'est les coups droits..
Jtrouve ça super dur de.. De doser le tsais l'effet que tu mets dans la balle.
NOON !
Jveux envoyer du rêve aux gens jveux mettre un smatch, jveux mettre, jte l'dis j'mettrai un smatch avant la fin.
PUTIN !
Pas grave j'remonte, 6-1 pour lui, mais j'remonte Clément.
OUI, OUI ! 6-2, c'est le début d'une grande remontée.
Non mais mec, pour de vrai, les smatchs c'est impossible, 9-2
9-2 c'est quoi c'est notre scène ça nous fait plaisir
Voilà super
10-2 c'est quoi ? c'est la défaite...
Allez on peut remonter !! Balle de match pour lui on peut mettre 8 points!!
10-3 c'est parti Clément
*soupir*
Tu sais ce qui s'est passé Clément ? Tu vois ces jambes c'est quoi ? C'est des piliers actuellement.
Et il faut que ce soit quoi ? DES GRENOUILLES!!!
Rematch !! Mec je veux gravir les échelons comme un chanteur après The Voice
1-0 pour lui
Ok...
Ce qui est drôle c'est que plus il me met une branlée plus il devient nul, ça c'est assez bien fait
C'est à dire que les développeurs se sont dit :
Bon les mecs sont nuls, on va quand même avoir un peu pitié d'eux.
Oh ça joue bien là !
Ohlala t'as vu j'ai fais un début de smash !
Attention le vrai smash arrive !
OOOOHHHH OUUUUIII!!!!! OOOH le smash !!
Celui-là tu mets un ralenti, tu mets les effets, tu mets Justin Bieber par dessus, tu fais
Merde
Mec je me dis dans le vraie vie, je dois tellement être une grosse merde à ce moment précis
Mais je te jure c'est hyper important faut que je gagne contre ce loup-garou
Oh mec, j'suis en train de dominer 4-3!!!
Tu vois le sport c'est aussi beaucoup de moral
Si le moral suit pas, le physique suit pas
C'est pas ça je voulais dire
Si le moral va pas, le physique ne suit pas
Ok 10-3 Clément BALLE DE MATCH
Allez service, hop là c'est mort
Oh la, taaahh
T'inquiètes l'petit smash
C'est pour vous attention smash !
ALLEZZZ
Allez à plus !
Bon mec il est temps de passer
A quelque chose de plus sérieux
Professionnel ? Ou légendaire ?
Je pense qu'on peux dire qu'on est des professionnels, ça fait 5 min qu'on joue
Allez, on est des pros
WAHOU!!!
Il a coupé-décalé mon gars !
Nan mais mec, il me met des balles c'est des fusées !
C'est des fusées ! Tu vois spacex bah il sponsorise ce mec
Allez balle de match pour lui, c'est parti, on remonte, on l'a laissé croire... allez c'est bon
Et y danse... rha j'ai envie de l'exploser
Il est virtuel hein ? Mais j'ai envie de l'exploser
Rematch ! C'est parti
*musique avec de la trompette*
OHH je lui ai mis un point ! J'lui ai mis un point c'est la victoire !
Je lui ai mis un point. On est équilibre le game ça fait qu'j'ai gagné
Alors on est donc maintenant en catégorie presque légendaire ça va être incroyable...
Oh... Bien joué, il fait des balles looooongues.
Mais mec ?!
Nan mais ... Ce n'est pas possible
*rire gêné*
Tu vois ces ptits mouvements vifs là?
C'est quand il m'explooose
T'as compté combien j'ai fais de mouvements vifs comme ça ?
Bah c'est le nombre de fois où il m'a explosé autant te dire que ...
Allez 11-0, c'est parti
Ohhh le mec il met, il met une carotte!!
Il me met une carotte dans le jeu !
Allez le smash, le smash.
MAIS MEC! Il me remet une carotte, il remet une carotte Clément
Putain, y remet, y remet une carotte !
*petits chouinements*
Nan mais mec ! Ahh ! Mec !
TRICHERIE !
Ma raquette passe à travers la  balle mec !
Regarde !
Clément ! 18 fois ma raquette est passée à travers la balle
Y a un problème avec ce jeu ou pas ?
A un moment faut pas déconner hein ?
Et y me remet, y *charabia* je
Je viens de remettre le casque, il m'a remis une carotte
OOHHHHH ! QU'ES CE QUE TU VAS FAIRE face à mes smashs ?
J'ai gagné, voilà c'était moi l'arbitre euh j'ai gagné
Si cette fin de vidéo ne te plaît pas *inspiration* bah j'comprends *rire*
Nan sans déconner c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur le jeu de ping-pong !
Hé! C'est hyper immersif de ouf et en fait dès que le jeu atteint une certaine  vitesse
Euh j'ai l'impression qu'avec la latence des capteurs etc
Il galère un ptit à ...C'est une excuse de rageux ou ? Tu ? C'est crédible ?
Ouais c'est une excuse de rageux.
A très vite dans une nouvelle vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé, portez vous bien!
Euh si vous voulez faire du ping-pong franchement, 20 balles par mois
Au club près de chez toi ! C'est mieux t'as vu ?
Abonnez vous !